ja wie gesagt das ist ein alptraum mit
dem auto ins wasser zu stürzen und dort
dann verzweifelt zu versuchen
möglicherweise minuten lang aus dem
fragt zu kommen darüber möchte ich jetzt
gerne sprechen mit dem digital chef der
auto bild mit robin horn ich grüße sie
genannt
wie viel zeit hat man in solchen horror
momenten wie viel zeit bleibt einem um
dann unter wasser aus dem auto fort
rauszukommen
der mann muss sich das wirklich
vorstellen das ist eine extreme
situation und da gilt ist egal wie
schlimm das jetzt gerade ist versuchen
ruhig zu bleiben sich zu fokussieren
panik und stress zu vermeiden weil das
kostet kraft und kraft brauche ich
fahrzeug schlägt auf möglicherweise geht
auch noch der airbag auch ab diesem
zeitpunkt habe ich circa 30 bis 60
sekunden zeit mich zu befreien bevor das
fahrzeug komplett unter wasser geht da
bringt es überhaupt nichts irgendwie an
einen notruf zu denken ist zählt jede
sekunde und da sind drei schritte enorm
wichtig der erste schritt wird öffnen
wenn es dunkel ist sich den ich sehe
ertasten runter führen zum gurtschloss
schloss öffnen möglicherweise mit
fahrern wie kindern in dem augenblick
helfen
zweiter schritt fenster öffnen oder
schiebedach solange die elektronik noch
funktioniert funktioniert elektronik
nicht kann ich das fenster versuchen
einzuschlagen die wenigsten werden
nothammer mit an bord haben was man
machen kann anderen gegenstand so wenn
ich habe das mal mitgebracht so eine
kopfstütze eignet sich dafür mit dem
unteren ende in einer der unteren ecken
der scheibe zu schlagen vor sich die
dinge lassen sich bei vielen fahrzeugen
nicht mehr so einfach lösen das muss man
vorher einmal ausprobiert haben es wird
aber dringend davon abgeraten die tür zu
öffnen
denn die türen des bereits unter wasser
der druck enorm groß der kraftaufwand
enorm
um zu einem tür zu öffnen wenn ich die
dann auch habe kommt sofort in jeder
menge wasser rein und das fahrzeug sinkt
noch viel schneller
das gleiche gilt im übrigen für die
frontscheiben sollte man nicht versuchen
ihn wieder raus zu treten denn das
fahrzeug sinkt am schnellsten da wo es
am schwersten ist also vorne wo der
motor drin
das heißt es kommt wieder viel wasser
rein man musste ihn gut lösen das
fenster öffnen und dann sofort raus
diese drei schritten sollte sich jeder
autofahrer einmal im auto bewusst machen
das versuchen wir nun muss man wissen du
warst selbst bei der marine hat sich
lange mit solchen situationen
beschäftigt mit denen beschäftigen wir
uns normalerweise im alltag gar nicht
aber lass uns noch mal auf diese
gegenstände gucken die du gerade genannt
hast ich habe dir im studio einmal
mitgebracht das ist so ein not
hämmerchen ich habe das noch nie in
meinem auto mit dabei gehabt ist das
deine empfehlung auf jeden fall das
gehört in die fahrertür ein und dann wie
ich den bediener ist glaube ich klar
damit schlag ich die scheibe ein
außerdem ist hier noch ein ja so eine
art messer dabei mit dem ich den gurt im
zweifel durch trennen kann
ist das deine empfehlung immer dabei
haben immer in der fahrertür
also ich hab selber auch nicht so einen
nothammer an bord ich denke seit heute
wahrscheinlich mehr darüber nach mir so
etwas ins auto zu tun wenn nicht so
etwas im auto habe dann muss ich aber
auch wissen wie ich das ganze einsetzt
ist bringt überhaupt nichts in so einer
stresssituation auch noch zu versuchen
das richtig anzuwenden das geht in der
regel schief also sollte man sich mal
einer eine scheibe nehmen wo man auch
die möglichkeit hat und mit so einem
hammer zu schlagen man redet in der
regel davon ab genau in die mitte zu
schlagen dann sollte sich eine untere
ecke eben suchen und und da rein
schlagen dieses gut messer brauche ich
ja wirklich nur wenn ich jemanden aus
einem fahrzeug heraus lösen muss der
ohnmächtig geworden ist in so einer
situation wo das fahrzeug ins wasser
daneben einschlägt habe ich in der regel
selber noch die möglichkeit nicht eben
zu befreien weil meine hände wohl noch
intakt sind das muss man ja so grausam
sagen und auch das gurtschloss noch
zugänglich ist also der hammer das ist
das entscheidend aber ich habe eben auch
gezeigt es gibt andere möglichkeiten
auch dieses fenster kaputt zu bekommen
man sollte aber dennoch versuchen als
allererstes das fenster ganz normal zu
öffnen
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren